michael engelberg unser reporter ist in
hamm vor ort an der geschichte dran
michael was ist da los in haben wie kann
es sein dass gefeiert wird mit dieser
vorgeschichte
ja hallo ich bin hier in hamm ich stehe
vor der event halle leider hier hat auch
vor zwei wochen die hannah party
stattgefunden eine art
junggesellinnenabschied das doofe war
zwei der besucherinnen waren dabei
corona positiv das wusste man aber nicht
dann hat sich das ganze wie ein
schneeball weitergetragen und dann durch
die durch die hochzeit sind ganz ganz
viele infiziert nun ja wie das kann das
hier wieder hochzeiten gefeiert werden
weil die stadt haben eine
allgemeinverfügung erlassen hat man muss
ganz ganz viele bedingungen erfüllen und
neben mir steht der besitzer der halle
das ist herr barschel herr branche seien
sie kurz eben welche bedingungen sie
erfüllen mussten damit sie hier
tatsächlich heute die hochzeit
durchführen können also wir müssen die
gäste ist schon viel vorher abgeben
mit namen natürlich anschrift in dem
entsprechen haben auch die genehmigungen
dafür bekommen natürlich bietet auf der
liste ob jemals schon corona gemeldet
ist oder nicht und finde das auch ganz
natürlich dass so ein rigoros kam dann
sind wir natürlich auf der sicheren
seite noch mehr
jetzt könnte man natürlich auch
nachfragen fühlen sich irgendwie auch so
ein bisschen mit schuld das jetzt hier
haben vielleicht versorgen vor so einem
lockdown steht weil es ja wie gesagt
schneeball mäßig hier in ihrem laden
quasi seinen anfang genommen haben also
mit schuld auf jeden fall nicht weil wir
haben uns auch an den regeln garten
wir haben auch gästeliste durchgeführt
gehabt hat auch gesundheitsamt von uns
verlangt gehabt den wir sofort praxen
könnten und dadurch auch die andere
gäste gedreht werden könnten
ok jetzt mit hannah begonnen da waren
leider zwei mitbewohner gewesen die vier
weitere infiziert hat aber die
hauptfahrbahn nicht hier gewesen die
hautfarbe in dortmund gewesen
und das war mit mehreren personen
gewesen so leider das ist dann vermehrt
nichtsdestotrotz liegt hier heute auf
der veranstaltung eine ganze menge druck
also ganz ganz viele gucken ja darauf
dass hier wirklich alles
das in ordnung ist haben sie heute schon
irgendwie von der polizei oder vom
ordnungsamt besuch bekommen haben die
irgendwas gesagt haben irgendwie was
beanstandet oft schon zu besuch hier
gewesen schon vor 1 stunde gewesen
die werden jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal
kommen und zu gucken ob wir uns an dem
regel halten
also wer bis heute andere uns an dem
regel garten gehabt mit den behörden
haben auch gut zusammengearbeitet die
haben uns auch sehr gut dafür
wir haben uns wie gesagt von anfang an
den regel garten mit dem abstand von dem
tisch für messe auch die feder von dem
gäste vorher
wir lassen die natürlich auch eintragen
und auch noch drauf dass jeder mit
abstand auf dem stuhl sitzen ist man mit
ihnen als besitzer umgegangen also war
haben sich was haben sie für
rückmeldungen bekommen über facebook
oder über das telefon
wie geht man mit jemandem der vielleicht
eventuell hier den london vielleicht
verursacht den anfang strecken also das
ist echt traurig gewesen dass ich weil
sozialen netzwerken bombardiert wurde
ich würde auch angerufen beleidigt als
ausländer ging ruhig haben wir in
deutschland diese krone also krone hat
sich nicht durch den hochzeiten gebildet
das haben wir ja schon viel vorher
bekommen da ist jetzt aus china kam wo
er anders wissen wir natürlich nicht
genauer es ist natürlich traurig dass
das verbreitet hat durch den rost feier
aber man kann jetzt nicht direkt diese
branche angreifen und behauptet dass
diese kolonne jetzt nur durch diese
branche entsteht
es könnte genauso perfekt herr passieren
können bei bordells wo auch
körperkontakt ist konnte auch überall
raus kommen also muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt bei der branche gewesen sein
der besitzer wird er allerdings den
ganzen abend bei der hochzeit dabei sein
wird natürlich gucken dass die regeln
eingehalten werden er hat personal die
darauf achten penibel darauf achten alle
tragen masken an schuhe dass die leute
ihre abstände einhalten das getanzt wird
auf abstand dass das essen auf abstand
verteilt wird und wie wir gerade schon
gehört haben stellt man sich auch darauf
ein dass das ordnungsamt kommt und noch
mal nach kopf weil diese veranstaltung
dieser hochzeit wird hier in haben quasi
als blaupause genommen wenn das hier
vernünftig funktioniert dann kann man
vielleicht in der stadt auch ein
bisschen entwarnung geben mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich hier das nächste video an
es nicht zu abonnieren